my guest tonight is a hilarious comedian
and actor who was stored in ratatouille
uh the king of queens and the goldbergs
his new podcast with his wife meredith
salinger
did you get my text drops tomorrow
please welcome one of our all-time
favorites pat nozzle
[Applause]
[Music]
so
wow uh
patton first of all uh thanks so much
for being here but i gotta say
you i know that you are a regular here
at the largo theater and i didn't get to
acknowledge that at the top of the show
the largo theater has been a lifesaver
for us this is
probably the premier uh live theater for
comedians in los angeles
and uh we've been doing our show out of
here and then to get to finish up our
run
here at this theater is very meaningful
and i could just see the look on your
face when you came out and you were back
as there's a there's a i'm gonna get all
choked up
there's a crowd at the largo i'm looking
at i haven't been in
i'm so happy right now i just want to
stay here this has been more than a year
i haven't seen
a crowd at the largo this is amazing so
i'm very very happy you know
i think the first thing we want to do is
catch up with how you are
how it's going because that's what i
find i'm doing is i'm talking to people
good friends
that i've been disconnected from from so
long i'll talk to him on zoom but it's
not the same
do you feel uh you feel safe i mean i
know you're
are you fully vaccinated i'm yes fully
vaccinated
um i okay listen i didn't
i didn't do any line jumping or use my
celebrity
to get vaccinated but i was here's how i
got vaccinated early i'm just
saying this now i have a friend a writer
friend who lives in riverside california
and he said look maybe i shouldn't tell
you this there's a rite aid near me
every time i walk in there's a woman
sitting at a card table
and she's begging people to get
vaccinated and i'm basically living in
mega country and no one will get their
shots
no one will get a shot from her if you
drive out here i
i guarantee you can just walk in and
they'll give you the shot but i made a
appointment i drove out there sure
enough
there were three people in line in front
of me and the the couple that was
in front of me had no uh id
or insurance card when they got up there
they would we don't we forgot to bring
it she's like
let's just get a needle in you that's
fine let's just get you vaccinated
and and as i was waiting i saw people
coming in and she would ask
everybody do you want to get vaccinated
and everyone was like
no no thank you and one guy did the uh
no like nice try deep state um
not today man like i've seen the
parallax view and you're not gonna be
it was i i just was so blown away yeah
that when the polio vaccine came out in
we were two years away from having
satellites for god's sakes
and the country could could not have
been more racist and backward and
horrible
and they brought out a vaccine and
people went put it in my arm and now
everybody everybody was like yay thank
you science
now it's 2021. we carry
portable world brains in our pockets
there are robots on mars
and people are going that vaccine's full
of witch poisoning
i ain't getting
[Laughter]
if this attitude existed in 1955 they
would have had to have one of those
like animated like like mascots like a
hypodermic needle
going who do i gotta blow to cure polio
so insane what a wonderful yeah
now did you get uh you know it's funny
because everyone approached the
quarantine differently did you get a lot
accomplished during the quarantine are
you one of those people that
took care of stuff i did the mistake and
i'm sure a lot of people did
too those first couple weeks i mapped
out i'm gonna get all these
books read i'm gonna have an exercise
regimen
i'm gonna use this time wisely and then
a month later i was having cheetos for
breakfast and
like re-watching uh like like shows i'd
seen a million times didn't read any
books i
i it took me a month to just and i
just went crazier than a barn full of
clown pubes like i was just
out of my freak look wait a minute i'm
not what are you
got to explain that one i'm not i look i
don't want to get canceled for that
okay i'm just saying clown clown pubes
are perfectly natural clown sex is fine
whatever
you want to do i'm not judging i'm
saying
cr the crazy is the person who gathered
up enough
pubes to fill a barn that is what i i
just want you to know
that i'm not putting the crazy on the
clown pubes it's the act of gathering
yes
enough clown pubes to fill a barnum
please yeah
i'm just clown pube shaming hurts all of
us and i don't want
that to be i just don't want that to be
a problem uh what about this what about
the fact because you're a guy
very thoughtful and i look to you for
the answers we're in a
why i just said barn full of clown
i know clearly a mistake on mine i got
drunk with a doll in 2013.
listen to me but in this post-pandemic
world
do you think life is going to be
different there are schools of thought
some people said it can be radically
different some people say we're going to
drift back to what we used to be
absolutely nothing is going to change i
remember
right when the pandemic started and it
got really bad i would sit around with
my wife and say well you know the
buffets are never coming back and kiss
that goodbye
buffets are gonna come back so hard and
they're gonna come back in that
defiant kind of like are you a or
can you
come and eat at the golden corral
we don't have any like they i i swear
it's gonna be
like we don't have any of those woke
sneeze guards like those
liberal left coast weirdos like come on
out here and
[Laughter]
[Music]
there's no sink in our bathroom we'll
build a caesar salad right in your mouth
can you take no sneeze guard dining or
can you not make love to your walk
buffets are going to come back here all
the cruise ships are already sold out
yes
they've sold their people have spent a
year watching
cruise ships mired off of coast because
they were full of plague and death and
now they're like well
i guess they're they're discounting it
now i mean
if the plague ship is expensive then no
but if they're gonna
throw in you know free water slide
passes like how can i say no
nothing will nothing will change nothing
will change all right and it's sad
you're in a marvel franchise now you're
the voice of marvel's what is it modok
mo doc uh it's a show now on hulu
uh that i co-created with a this
brilliant writer named jordan bloom and
modoc is
modoc is basically the most
crapped upon marvel super villain his
name stands for
a mobile organism designed only for
killing he is a gigantic
floating head in this weird seat with
these tiny little arms and legs and
like jack kirby created him on a bad day
like he
either had like some bad corned beef
he's like oh god
and this drew this giant angry head and
from the get-go
all people do is make fun of this poor
guys we're like this is going to be our
marvel show the worst
super villain in the marvel universe we
kind of go into his life
where he's determined to conquer the
world
but unlike those idiots dr doom and
madame mask
who can't also conquer the world and
have a family and children i'm gonna do
both
so he he is determined to have a nice
wife and kids in the suburbs but then
also
destroy the planet at the same time it's
just it's it's complete
delusion and sadness and it was so fun
to do but this is i mean you're working
with the marvel people and they kind of
own
you know deluxe entertainment now there
must be great perks working for the
marvel people oh my god
yeah you get all kinds of um uh
oh god oh my god there's stuff i can't
talk about there's stuff that i've seen
that i can't talk about yet
right oh boy that sounds ominous no but
i'm just saying
they're like we get to see stuff that's
up what do they do to you
yeah well no i can tell you one thing
in next in 2022 they're going to do a
[Laughter]
super
and the one thing that was weird about
doing modoc was we asked for characters
from the marvel kind of toy box that
we're like well they'll just say no to
this one but we'll be able to get this
one
right they said yes to every thing that
we asked for
every character we wanted to use or like
go right ahead and we're like
really like oh absolutely but then there
were these other
random minor characters like there's
this one guy named stilt man
who was one of daredevils or thank you
for one guy
yes final yes
it is and holy i'm still yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it is like something you guys would
create for one of your
sketches it is a and he's exactly what i
just said he's a guy who has these legs
that he can make really long and just
kind of go up like be tall and grab
things out of buildings
it's stilt man and so we're like we want
stilt man for this one scene and they
were like
no you can't have stilt man we're like
i'm sorry we can have
iron man and mr sinister but we can't
have stiltman
no which makes me think are they going
to use stiltman for something like that
and also it sounds like they're going to
use them for something major and big
like did they did they get joaquin
phoenix to agree to places
that's gonna be their ask i don't know
but like it's so amazing something big
is in the works for stilt man and you
stumbled into it
yeah i mean it was like just so
intriguing the stuff that that's going
on there i love it
i gotta ask you about because it drops
tomorrow your podcast
yes this is the podcast uh did you get
my text
and you do this with your wife and this
tell us about it it is
basically i think what a lot of people
have been experiencing in
quarantine and in life my my wife and i
the lovely meredith salinger
live in a house together but half of the
day even though we're
never more than 60 feet apart we just
text each other stuff
we can easily just go hey sweetie did
you see this but we'll just text stuff
i'll probably get a ton of great stuff
oh my god yeah it's that it's that great
thing of when you're sitting around
with someone and you start just hey
what's been going on
and it starts off with small talk and
then it ends up into these giant
rolling conversations and it's really
really fun the um i did want to bring up
uh i'm getting sentimental uh at this
stage of things
and i wanted to bring up that you
started coming on
our late night show in the real early
days really really early
and um and then throughout the years
in the different iterations of the show
uh
you've always been there for us and i
really
you you've been a important part of you
know what we wanted to do with this show
your
your comedy is so original and left
brain and
it was just it's always been very nice
for us to have you
come and be like a big part of what we
were trying to do thank well it meant a
lot to me
and i know that i can speak for like all
my comedian
kind of posse that your show especially
that
it reminded me of the way letterman's
show was back in the day of oh
our kind of comedy is getting some
representation this really
weird why not i want to try something i
mean the stuff that
the stuff that i could the artie kendall
the ghost crooner
that i one day i was working on a
tv show and for some reason the theme
song
for uh rockabilly polka polka-dotted
embryonic fighter pilots got stuck in my
head yeah which is one of your things
like
little things like that that you're like
i have this idea i don't
really know what to do with it let's put
it out to see what happens with it like
that kind of
that the fact that that got to have
exposure
really really was a big deal for me you
know kept
kept a lot of us going yeah yeah well it
was uh
you know it's so as you can attest to
and you too andy when you
when you get to do the thing you dreamed
of as a kid that's so stupid
and it's the thing that you get yelled
at because people say stop doing that
stop screwing around
and get to and get to work and then you
grow up and someone says if you'll do
that
we'll give you a paycheck uh it's i
don't i don't think there's anything
more miraculous
in life it's just really nice the look
on your face when you would do
the random chuck norris texas ranger
lever
but the look on your yeah but that
when you would do it like the third or
fourth time there was that look of like
i'm still can you believe i'm like dude
like you were so happy
we used to pull this lever and it would
show clips of
these scenes from uh uh from texas
ranger
chuck yeah uh walker texas ranger and we
would show these clips and they were the
most insane clips
and you can and so what happened was we
loved it it was my favorite thing and
then we were told that you have to stop
doing it and i said why
they said because all the actors want to
get uh you have to pay all the actors
uh and it's a fortune and if you don't
stop immediately
i mean literally it would have
bankrupted the show bankrupted all of us
you have to stop immediately and i was
crushed because i loved it and then i
told my producer no
we're taking this to trial and he said
what are you talking about and i said i
want to go to trial and i want to show
these
i want to show these clips and then i
want to turn to the jury and say
do you really think that's acting
[Laughter]
i would have won you would have i would
have won
oh my god we gotta i know i know uh
it'll happen in my next life yeah
patton's podcast with his wife meredith
salinger
did you get my text premieres tomorrow
uh
wherever you get podcasts yes uh you
know thank you
so much for being such a big part of our
foolishness over the years pat and
oswald we'll take a break we'll be right
back